هشام كيف هي الاوضاع في غزه الهدوء الحذر
مستمره ليس كذلك
[موسيقى]
هو هدوء حذر نوعا ما محمد لكن هذا الهدوء
تخترقه ما بين الفينه والاخرى غارات
اسرائيليه تتجدد على اراضي زراعيه في قطاع
غزه هذه الليله ومن بعد منتصف هذه الليله
الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه تركز قصفها
وغاراتها على اراض زراعيه في انحاء مختلفه
من قطاع غزه اخر هذه الغارات كانت في دير
البلح وسط قطاع غزه وايضا في بيت حنون في
شمال القطاع واستهدفت هي الاخرى اراض
زراعيه في تلك المناطق هذه الغارات ايضا
كانت قبل عده ساعات ايضا على اراضي زراعيه
في مخيم النصيرات وسط قطاع غزه وموقعا
للمقاومه كذلك استهدفتها الطائرات الحربيه
بعدد من الصواريخ الموقع الابرز كان في
شمال مخيم النصيرات بالقرب من محطه توليد
الكهرباء الوحيده في القطاع واستهدفته
الطائرات الحربيه
التي تراقب عن كثب ما يجري على الارض او
تلك التي تحمل الذخيره وتطلق الصواريخ ما
بين الفين والاخرى على اهداف معينه في
قطاع غزه واستهدفت ما بعد منتصف الليل شق
سكنيه في حيتل الهوى في الغرب من مدينه
غزه واصيب على اثر هذه الغاره الاسرائيليه
احد المواطنين الفلسطينيين الذين الذي تم
نقله الى المشفى لتلقي العلاج بينما
استشهد فلسطيني في غاره جاءت بعد منتصف
الليل على ذات المنطقه في مخيم النصيرات
الى الشمال من المخيم وهي ارض زراعيه
بالتاكيد نحن نتحدث عن اراضي زراعيه يحدها
الكثير من منازل المواطنين واستشهد على
اثر هذه الغرس الغاره على الارض الزراعيه
في شمال مخيم النصيرات احد المواطنين
الفلسطينيين واعلن عن استشهاد وبذلك ارتفع
عدد الشهداء جراء هذه الموجه من التصعيد
والمتواصله منذ اربعه ايام الى ثلاثين
شهيدا ونحو 100 جريح جراء هذه الغارات
الاسرائيليه المتواصله على قطاع غزه هذا
في الجانب الميداني ايضا واصلت المقاومه
الفلسطينيه اطلاق الرشقات الصاروخيه لكن
منذ التاسعه من مساء امس لم نشهد رشقات
صاروخيه مكثفه بعد تلك الابرز التي انطلقت
الى تل ابيب
واصابت العديد من المباني هناك وهذه
الرشقات الصاروخيه فقط اطلقت بعد منتصف
الليل المقاومه الفلسطينيه صاروخ واحد
رصدناه من بعد منتصف هذه الليله اذن
الصواريخ خفت حدتها من قطاع غزه وايضا
الغارات الاسرائيليه خفت حدتها لكنها لا
تزال متواصله لا نستطيع القول ربما ان
هناك حاله من الهدوء التام لكنه هدوء حذر
يتجدد بعده الغارات ما بين الفين والاخ